hi I'm Michelle and I have a blow cold
love muffin today I'm going to be
talking about why pH matters for alpha
hydroxy acids and vitamin C there are
many acidic active ingredients in
skincare alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic lactic and malic acids beta
hydroxy acid or salicylic acid vitamin C
or l-ascorbic acid hyaluronic acid
retinoic acid and many more you might
have heard that some other products need
to be a certain pH to work why is that
here's the science behind the skincare
tip
acids and molecules that can give up
hydrogen ions or H+ for example sulfuric
acid or battery acid is hash to SF or
hydrochloric acid in your stomach is HCl
and acetic acid in vinegar is ch3cooh
all of them can break up to give up
hydrogen ions like so you can see that
the acids in skincare also have hydrogen
that can break off
the top layer of the skin the stratum
corneum is made up of cells embedded in
oily lipids much like bricks and mortar
oil is nonpolar which means it isn't
charged while water is polar which means
it's partially charged according to the
rule of thumb for solubility like
dissolves like that is things that are
uncharged would like to mingle with
things that are also uncharged but
they'll repel things that are charged
this means that in general charged
particles will not get into skin easily
when assets haven't given up their
hydrogen ions their uncharged so they're
able to penetrate the stratum corneum
the uncharged version is called the free
acid but if they've broken up or
dissociated into a hydrogen ion and a
negatively charged anion they're two
polar to get through the nonpolar
stratum corneum very easily the extent
to which the acid is broken up depends
on a few things let's talk about the two
that are most important in skincare
first the strength of the bond holding
the hydrogen iron to the rest of the
acid this is measured by something
called the pKa of the acid for example
hydrochloric acid has a very low PKA so
in water based solutions it's almost
100% broken up acetic acid on the other
hand has a much higher PKA so in water
only about 1 in 100 acidic hydrogen's
have broken off we call the strong and
weak skincare acids are all weak acids
so their varying amounts of broken up
secondly there's also the pH of the
overall product pH measures the total
concentration of hydrogen ions and low
pH means more hydrogen the hydrogen ions
can come from the skincare acid or from
other acids added to the mixture let's
consider a product where half the acid
molecules own the free acid form so half
can get into the skin if the pH is lower
there's more hydrogen ions around which
means more will attach onto the acid
molecules giving more of the uncharged
free acid which can penetrate this means
that a lower concentration of acid at a
lower pH will give the equivalent amount
of free acid as a higher concentration
at a higher pH for example a product
with 10% glycolic acid at pH 3 would
have 8 point 7 percent of the product in
uncharged form whereas that ph 4.5 you'd
need 50% glycolic acid to get a similar
amount in summary low pH will always
increase the amount of uncharged acids
that will penetrate the skin and the pH
required to get a high concentration of
uncharged acid depends on which are
supporting about why not use a super low
pH then you'd be correct in thinking
that if we used a really low pH that
would give us the maximum amount of
uncharged acid that could penetrate
unfortunately skin likes to be at around
pH 5 and very low pH can cause chemical
burns
the levon products is recommended that
you use alpha hydroxy acids at a pH of
less than four and a concentration with
between four and ten percent and a score
the acid at a pH of around 3.5 and a
concentration between five and twenty
percent
what about the other acids it gets more
complex here because the rest of the
acid molecule makes a big difference
hyaluronic acid is a large polymer made
up of thousands of these units so it's
way too big to get into the skin anyway
and it doesn't need to
it's a humectant moisturizer which means
it sits on top of skin and holds on to
water to keep your skin moist for
retinoic acid the rest of the molecule
is nonpolar enough that the charge
doesn't make a big difference for
salicylic acid or beta hydroxy acid it's
often recommended that you use a product
with a pH of less than 3.5 and a
concentration of one to two percent but
there from evidence that it's also
non-polar enough that pH doesn't matter
that's a quick introduction to deviation
acids in skincare I definitely haven't
covered everything because delivering
things through skin is a huge huge topic
I hope you found this video useful and
if you'd like to see more videos like
this from me in the future please
comment and let me know